[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview mme pour ce nouveau
numéro on va s'intéresser à ce scandale
qui entache l'église catholique depuis
plusieurs années est les révélations
d'actes pédophiles mine elle par des
prêtres se sont succédé partout dans le
monde
après des années de silence et tant de
vies gâchées l'institution s'engage
aujourd'hui à faire la lumière
un grand travail d' enquête est en cours
pour comprendre l'ampleur du phénomène
c'est la commission indépendante sur les
abus sexuels dans l'église qui en est
chargée elle a été créée il y a deux en
novembre 2018
à la demande des évêques de france et
des religieux et religieuses de france
est justement pour en parler avec nous
véronique margron présidente de la
corref c'est la conférence des religieux
et religieuses de france véronique
margron merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors vous êtes l'une des rares femmes
dans l'église de france à avoir une
haute fonction et l'une des grandes voix
pour faire la lumière sur les horreurs
qui se sont vécues au sein de l'église
vos fonctions auraient pu vous inciter
finalement une certaine réserve mais ce
n'est pas votre choix pourquoi je n'ai
pas mon choix parce qu'à vrai dire je
pense qu'il n'y a pas le choix
de tels scandales de tels drames de
telles tragédies dans la vie oblige à la
vérité et si j'essaie de vivre un temps
soit peu ma vie chrétienne
cette vérité est d'autant plus
nécessaire elle est nécessaire elle est
impérative au relèvement à pour
participer un tant soit peu du
relèvement des personnes victimes et
elle est impérative pour espérer que
l'église tout entière en tout cas pour
ce qui est de l'église en france
puissent changer tout ce qui doit l'être
et hélas aussi faire la vérité regarder
en face cette bien tragique et
scandaleuse histoire votre regard c'est
aussi celui d'une femme dans une église
où la hiérarchie est principalement
composée d'hommes
en quoi votre regard justement
pourrait-il différé sur ces scandales
des hommes qui vous entourent
je ne sais pas si jamais facile de
répondre à cette question en quoi le
regard des femmes différents tirs de de
celui des hommes c'est bien difficile ce
que je peux dire c'est que peut-être une
des particularités c'est qu'en fin de
compte dans nos instituts religieux
féminin nous rencontrons aussi un
certain nombre de deux soeurs de membres
qui ont été victimes
alors il y en a aussi dans les instituts
masculin mais c'est peut-être aussi cela
qui donne une sensibilité particulière
j'écoute aussi des personnes dans la vie
a été bouleversée voir fracassé depuis
depuis très longtemps
peut-être aussi que le fait de
évidemment de ne pas être prêtre peut
aider à cette distance dans un premier
temps en tout cas à avoir un autre
regard je ne sais pas très bien je pense
que c'est un mélange de tout cela qui
fait que nous n'avons pas exactement la
même sensibilité et que cela c'est
peut-être en tout cas nous nous on ne
ressemble beaucoup à l'intérieur de la
conférence des religieux et religieuses
de france puisque par définition c'est
un organe mixte et on sent bien que la
place des femmes et des hommes donnent
une sensibilité spécifique à cette
assemblée
alors je vous propose de revenir au fait
j'en parlais à la commission
indépendante présidée par jean marc
sauvé il est vice président honoraire du
conseil d'état et bien cette commission
a livré fin octobre un premier rapport
pour permettre d'évaluer l'ampleur de la
pédocriminalité dans l'église alors ses
premiers chiffres 1 de 1950 à
aujourd'hui le travail de la commission
a permis d'identifier trois mille
victimes 1500 agresseurs quand vous
découvrez ces chiffres comment est-ce
que vous réagissez comment dire de deux
manières tout d'abord en se disant que
bien tragiquement ces chiffres sont
forcément très en deçà de la réalité
puisque des victimes sont décédées des
victimes ne peuvent pas parler peut-être
ne parleront jamais nous ne parlerons
que dans dix ans donc dire 3000 la
commission sauvé a recueilli 6500
témoignages 6500 appel qui se sont
traduits par environ 3000 long
questionnaire documenté qui servent donc
de matière
au travail de la commission c'est donc à
la fois rendre compte que nous ne sommes
pas devant des questions comment dire
cela où il y aurait seulement des
agresseurs individuelles bien sûr que
les agresseurs sont toujours des
individus nominatif prêtres religieux
parfois religieuse beaucoup plus
exceptionnellement mais ça arrive aussi
mais qui ça montre cette tragédie qui
lie à un système au tour c'est-à-dire
comment des agresseurs ont-ils pu
agresser 10/20 parfois trente ans
ont-ils pu aller parfois d'un bout à
l'autre de la france parfois du monde
comme religieux d'un diocèse à l'autre
d'un pays à l'autre
donc c'est la noise numérique c'est quoi
c'est finalement cette question du
secret cette question de l'opacité dans
l'église qui a pu y avoir pendant tant
d'années aujourd'hui qui est sur la
table c'est à la fois la question du
secret mais c'est aussi une question
tragiquement sociétal celle du déni
ces crimes celle de la minimisation des
faits qu'on voit aussi on a vu aussi
bien ailleurs dans la société française
que ce soit dans le monde du sport de la
famille de la culture la tragédie
initiés qu' on aurait pu penser que
l'église parce qu'elle est une
institution fondée sur les ventes il
donc sur un soin des plus fragiles que
l'église n'aurait pas été comme les
autres institutions et le tragique c'est
que si elle a été au moins comme les
autres institutions
donc c'est tous ces phénomènes cumulé
celui du secret mais aussi celui du déni
de la minimisation des faits de ne pas
croire les victimes de ne pas croire les
enfants et puis peut-être que comment
dire le crime est tellement épouvantable
que je pense qu'une partie de l'église
mais comme une partie de la société ne
veut pas le voir et donc le phénomène du
déni peut être renforcée par cela c'est
tellement impossible c'est tellement
incroyable c'est tellement impensable
qu'en fin de compte on essaie de passer
à côté et je pense que tous ces
phénomènes cumulés ont amené à ceux à ce
silence et à cette sorte de système
non pas que quelqu'un ait voulu tous ces
crimes de façon organisée bien
évidemment non mais c'est cette
conjonction de phénomènes
c'est cela qui rend la chose systémique
qui rend ces violences systémique parce
qu'en fin de compte elles ont été
dédaignés quand les enfants ont essayé
de parler quand ils sont allés voir un
prêtre un autre prêtre quelqu'un en
responsabilités dans l'église où elles
ont été minimisés ou pire on ne les a
pas crues
ni eux ni leurs parents mais est ce que
ça veut dire que la structure de
l'église dans sa forme
cette institution et bien finalement ça
un terreau à ça peut être un terreau
pour les prédateurs
vous savez j'ose espérer que non mais on
peut penser que que ça peut l'être si
nous ne faisons pas plus attention que
nous n'avons fait hier mais d'abord
parce que dans l'église il y a des
enfants
- les enfants qui viennent avec leur
famille les enfants qui sont au
catéchisme à les enfants qui sont dans
les chorales et que dès qu'il y ait des
enfants
il y a le danger que des hommes en fin
de compte choisi cette voie
consciemment ou inconsciemment pour être
proches d'enfants mais comme on voit ce
phénomène par exemple à l'éducation
nationale où dans le monde plus
largement de l'école ou de houe de
l'éducation combien aujourd'hui nous
avons appris à faire attention au
recrutement parce qu'on sait bien que ça
peut être un tragique terreau favorable
parce que la fragilité de l'enfant et le
fait qu'il va être en situation de
dépendance vis-à-vis de l'adulte peut
malheureusement en inciter certains donc
j'ose penser que ça n'est pas un terreau
en tout cas dans sa fille dans la
fondation même de l'église évidemment
dans son sens mais l'organisation
ecclésiale tout simplement le fait que
nous nous que dans l'église il y ait des
enfants et heureusement qu'il y en a peu
obligeant tout cas à encore plus de
vigilance
alors ce fléau de la pédocriminalité
dans l'église on en prend conscience
avec la sphère prénat qui deviendra
ensuite la sphère barbarin on s'en
souvient elle éclate en janvier 2016
alors que des victimes décident cette
fois de parler on saura plus tard qu'il
aurait eu beaucoup d'affaires un bien
avant en tout cas cette affaire en quoi
est-ce qu'il a un tournant pour l'église
et pour la société
je pense qu'elle est un tournant
essentiellement de par le courage des
victimes à prendre
parole à dire vraiment le tournant
décisif de la sphère prêt n'a cessé non
pas bernard prennent acte comme comme un
agresseur un prédateur car
malheureusement il y en a une autre bien
avant lui il y en a d'autres mais le
fait que la les victimes vont oser
prendre la parole et vont oser prendre
la parole ensemble donc vont faire une
force
et c'est cela qui va l'emporter c'est à
dire que on le voit très bien dans ce
très beau film grâce à dieu t'a dire que
le fait que les que les victimes ça
semble qu'elle se donne du courage
qu'elle rassemble un ensemble leur
courage
quelque chose à des porter plainte et
donc elle au sortir de l'église
bah on le voit aussi dans ce film
combien le premier réflexe car
évidemment tous ces enfants agressés
étaient des enfants de familles
catholiques eux-mêmes catholique bien
évidemment c'est ce ne sont pas des
rencontres fortuites
donc ces enfants sont pour beaucoup
d'entre eux pas tous mais un certain
nombre d'entre eux sont restés croyant
donc le premier réflexe adulte quand
elles parviennent à parler c'est de
s'adresser à l'église et donc le film
montre bien que à un moment donné le
fait d'être ensemble leur fait
comprendre que non ils font aussi
s'adresser à la justice de notre pays et
donc pour moi le tournant c'est cela
assez c'est l'extraordinaire courage des
victimes
le fait de fonder une association qui
aura eu un rôle très important en france
la parole libérée qui va rendre possible
une sorte de fédération de souffrance au
combien injuste et tragique et cela
c'est un vrai tournant et et franchement
enfin nous leur devons beaucoup à ce
moment là est ce que vous estimez
finalement que là il ya la hiérarchie
dans l'église catholique prend le
problème à bras le corps alors elle
avait déjà pris le problème en en partie
au moins des des années 2000 puisque dès
les années 2000 ce qu'on avait appelé la
sphère piquant il y avait eu beaucoup de
formations sur ces questions il y avait
eu des conférences des évêques sur ce
sujet qu'il y avait eu des manuels
de prévention donc il y avait eu des
choses mais on voit bien que tout ce qui
avait été fait à ce moment là était bien
loin d'être suffisant la preuve parce
que le silence a continué tout cela a
continué donc on peut dire que bien
tragiquement avec les affaires plus
récentes
là je pense que l'église et puis aussi
c'est l'arrivée du pape françois fin
déjà la fin du pontificat de benoît qui
déjà a été très très clair sur ces
questions là puis évidemment du pape
françois pour manifester clairement que
nous étions non peuvent façade et à des
fautes mais face à des crimes a donc on
en parle d'une autre nature quand même
un les montrent un poids donc quand on
parle de crime de deux crimes
évidemment au sens de ce qu'on peut dire
dans les familles au sens d inceste mais
aussi de crimes parce que ceux ci vient
toucher le coeur de la confiance de ses
enfants et de ses adultes d'aujourd'hui
puisque tous et toutes ces agressions
ont été commises dans le cadre d'un abus
de confiance puisque évidemment les
enfants connaissaient les prêtres en
question des religions en question avec
confiance en eux souvent les familles il
est considéré bien naturellement quelque
sorte d'ode du sein de l'église
catholique comme des hommes de dieu donc
ses hommes avait une aura particulière
une autorité extrêmement grande quasi
intouchable tragiquement intouchable en
quelque sorte un donc c'est le crime il
est aussi là il est d'avoir trahi la
confiance
véronique margron vous restez avec nous
on fait une petite pause on continue de
parler de cette question douloureuse de
la pédocriminalité dans l'église a tout
de suite
[Musique]
et on retrouve véronique margron la
présidente de la conférence des
religieux et religieuses de france pour
parler de la lutte contre la pédo mais
criminalité aujourd'hui dans l'église
véronique margron vous parliez à
l'instant de la question de l'autorité
finalement la question de pouvoir là
aussi toutes ces affaires de pédophilie
la réalité dans les livres elles ont
interrogé cette notion de pouvoir au
sein de l'institution
bien sûr non en tout cas elle interroge
après nous nous sommes loin du bout du
chemin à vous savez des institutions se
réforment lentement l'église peut être
encore plus lentement je ne sais pas
mais mais en tout cas je pense que la
prise de conscience et fait que toute
autorité qui se croient absolue d'abord
est fausse et met en danger les plus
vulnérables puisque en quelque sorte il
y à une sorte de sortie de la loi si
vous êtes de l'autorité suprême alors
vous n'êtes pas soumis à la loi et on le
sait bien en plus dans des personnalités
pédocriminels dans des personnalités
type pervers
combien déjà il y a un rapport à la
toute puissance chez ces hommes alors a
fortiori du coup dans l'église c'est à
dire marquer d'une sorte de caractère
sacré absolue et bien évidemment que
c'est toute puissance est encore plus
garantie en quelque sorte
donc ceci nous montre combien nous avons
besoin d'altérité dans la société dans
tous nos milieux mais dans l'église
catholique aussi ô combien c'est à dire
plus il y aura d'altérité plus il y aura
en quelque sorte de va et vient de
pluralité des responsabilités des
autorités est bien plus d'abord plus je
pense
nous serons une institution scène mais
plus aussi je pense que les plus
fragiles dont les enfants seront plus
protégés
alors après ces scandales il ya cette
question ce nouveau ce débat qui était à
nouveau sur la table la question du
célibat des prêtres dans l'église est on
le rappelle chez les orthodoxes les
protestants chez les maronites c'est le
cas les prêts peuvent se marier
est ce que c'est une question selon vous
qui doit se poser après ces affaires
alors je pense qu'il faut faire des
distinctions que la question du célibat
des prêtres se pose où puissent se poser
c'est bien normal il n'y a pas de raison
que cette question ne puisse pas être
débattus par contre je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention à ne pas la lier à
la question de la pédocriminalité car
sinon d'abord c'est donner un rôle assez
étrange et assez problématique aux
femmes comme si le fait d'avoir une
relation affective sexuelle avec une
femme allait empêcher toute toute
pulsion et tout passage à l'acte
pédocriminels à ce moment là il y aurait
aucun inceste donc ça se saurait donc
bien malheureusement c'est pas vrai et
c'est une drôle de façon de considérer
les femmes un peu comme des instruments
si on fait cela donc je pense que c'est
pas très juste de se dire la solution
serait ce côté là et on sait aussi dans
des études qui sont faites plus tôt dans
le monde anglo saxon plutôt aux états
unis combien des communautés par exemple
évangélique donc de tradition
protestante où les pasteurs sont mariés
ne sont pas exemple bien loin s'en faut
bien tragiquement ne de nombreux
problèmes de pédocriminalité donc je
pense qu'il faut distinguer les choses
la question c'est plutôt qu'est ce qui
favorise l'équilibré psychique
l'equilibre psychosexuel de quelqu'un et
en l'occurrence qu'est ce qui va
favoriser l' équilibre psychosexuel
comme manière de vivre pour un prêtre
qui est aujourd'hui dans l'église
catholique
un homme célibataire c'est plus de ce
point de vue là me semble-t-il qu'il
faut prendre la question est justement
sur la c'est la question de la sexualité
aujourd'hui dans l'église les religieux
les religieuses les prêtres qui ont la
vocation aujourd'hui qu'en est il de
cette question de la sexualité on a le
sentiment qu'elle est à bout 1 toujours
aujourd'hui dans l'église il ya une
formation spécifique ça a soulevé des là
encore des questions il ya des personnes
qui travaillent sur le dossier
oui beaucoup beaucoup depuis longtemps
pour le coup c'est à dire moi j'ai
enseigné dans des séminaires c'est à
dire des lieux de formation pour les
futurs prêtres pendant
des années des années je peux pas vous
dire depuis quand il y à cette réflexion
mais au moins depuis 30 ans donc elle
n'est pas du tout dit hier il y à des
cours spécifiques de ce qu'on appelle
deux des tic liées aux questions de
sexualité sûr aussi les justes
comportement il y a souvent des
réflexions faites avec des psychologues
et psychiatres donc des choses sont
faites
après la question c'est à la fois les
repères intellectuels en quelque sorte
mais c'est une loi fictif mais c'est
aussi l'accompagnement des personnes le
compagnonnage avec les personnes choisir
une vie quelle qu'elle soit nous savons
tous et chacun que ça n'est pas si
facile
il restait fidèle avec du sens et eon
s'épanouissant suffisamment c'est à dire
en ayant le sentiment que voilà qu'on
est soi même ça n'est pas non plus si
simple que ça au fil des événements de
sa vie
donc c'est au moins autant cela à la
question donc je ne crois pas
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait tellement de
tabous sur cela on en discute je vous
dirai pas tous les jours mais on discute
régulièrement et avec des outils je
crois beaucoup plus ajustée qui hier
autrement dit sensme il ne s'agit plus
de faire des sortes de leçon de morale
ou de recouvrir tout cela sur une sorte
de deux manteaux spirituelle comme si la
prière où la spiritualité
allez tout arranger fr le corps résiste
et bien évidemment donc je pense qu'on a
de meilleurs outils de meilleur
médiation reste le compagnonnage des
personnes dans les moments difficiles
dans les moments de formation
c'est à dire dans les moments de
fragilité ou la personnalité se remanie
en quelque sorte
en tout cas vous parlez souvent des 12
travaux de l'église
comment l'église aujourd'hui peut se
réinventer
selon vous alors se réinventer ce serait
sans doute plus que prétentieux et je ne
sais pas si c'est nécessaire mais en
tout cas faire des mutations nécessaires
ou des évolutions indispensables cela
oui alors on peut dire que déjà avec le
concile vatican 2 donc déjà les depuis
les années soixante à certains de ces
mutations sont entreprises par exemple
sur la place des laïcs dans l'église
dont les femmes alors on peut dire vous
le disais au début de notre émission que
nous sommes loin du compte mais par
rapport à il ya 50 ans ou 60 ans et
voilà du chemin a été fait donc après
peut toujours penser on n'a pas
forcément tort
il est loin d'être abouti mais du chemin
a été fait c'est aussi avoir une église
plus plus modestes non c'est à dire que
dans la société on le voit bien
aujourd'hui dans la société française
l'église catholique est une parmi
d'autres un culte parmi d'autres et une
voix vo x parmi d'autres dans les prises
de parole du débat public
il faut qu'elle parle c'est normal ça
fait partie de son rôle mais elle n'a
pas à imaginer quelle aurait une sorte
de prétention à détenir l'absolue vérité
donc c'est aussi une église plus
servante de nos sociétés donc pour moi
ce sont des mutations qui ont commencé
mais mais la tragédie la force de cette
crise
et puis sa violence c'est à dire se dire
comment une institution qui prétend être
là pour pour dire quelque chose du salut
de dieu c'est à dire d'une bonne
nouvelle à d'un dieu de bonté qui relève
comment at elle pu porter la mort ça
c'est une question éminemment
douloureuse pour moi pour nous tous de
dire mais comment c'est possible d'avoir
été d'avoir à ce point trahi le coeur de
nous mêmes donc ça ça doit nous obliger
à changer plus encore et vous vous avez
des éléments de réponse sur ce sur cette
interrogation c'est difficile mais
quelques uns sans doute je pense que il
y as peut-être quelque chose du côté du
sacré c'est à dire comment de vous dire
ça le fait de poser quelqu'un comme
sacrée il n'y a plus d'esprit critique
si vous considérez qu'une chose est
sacrée alors on la critique plus si vous
considérez pour prendre notre situation
bien que douloureuse d'aujourd'hui avec
lakovic 19
si vous considérez que la parole de tel
ou tel professeur ou de tel ou tel
chercheur est sacré et à dire que voilà
rien ne peut la contredire
et bien du coup l'ex prix critiques ne
s'exerce plus donc le rapport aux sacs
au sacré qui est si fort dans toutes les
religions qui fait partie d'une grosse
question dans le christianisme parce que
le christianisme comment vous dire
évangélise le sacré pour lui empêché
d'être séparé de l'humanité parce que ça
crée ça veut dire ce qui est séparée et
tout ce qui séparait bien on a bien du
mal à le à le critiquer comment vous
dire ça à le laisser à regard à hauteur
d'homme et tout ce qu'on met sur un
piédestal et dangereux donc ça je pense
que ça c'est un vrai chemin et plus
j'ose espérer nous commençons
entreprendre mais qui est loin d'être
terminée donc il y a cet aspect là il y
à tout ce qu'on vit dans l'église
catholique sur le rapport aux sacrements
la messe la confession on voit bien que
ces lieux là ont pu être des lieux de
grands dangers pour des enfants parce
qu'à nouveau le prêtre dans ces moments
là est à part et donc ça interroge cette
même question des hommes à part comment
à la fois avoir un statut particulier ce
qui est bien normal dans l'église
catholique et en même temps ne pas être
considéré comme un homme à part parce
qu'alors du côté de personnalités
perverses et bien ses hommes à part se
croient ou peuvent ou pourraient se
croire ou se sont cru tout permis
alors des questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui finalement que grâce au fait
que des personnes aient libéré la parole
vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure ses
victimes
comment elles sont accompagnées
aujourd'hui notamment par l'église de
quelle manière
alors de toute façon pas assez je pense
que c'est la première réponse à faire un
pas assez et je pense que nous serons
ici toujours en tête enfin le malade que
quoi qu'on fasse ça sera toujours en
deçà de ce qu'on aurait dû faire parce
que ces femmes et ces hommes n'auraient
jamais dû être victimes
donc de toutes façons tout ce qu'on
essaiera de réparer sera peu de chose
face à l'irréparable de la souffrance de
la douleur parfois de l'empêchement à
être que ces femmes et ces hommes ont
vécu en dur et souvent en dure encore
aujourd'hui y compris 10 20 30 ans 40
ans parfois à 50 ans parfois même après
après ce qu'elles ont subi
donc un certain nombre de personnes
victimes et ça pour moi c'est quelque
chose qui me bouleverse
sans cesse ont accepté de travailler
avec nous donc sont dans nos groupes de
travail dans les réflexions sur tous les
points qu'on abordait et c'est en fin de
compte très important parce que je pense
qu'elles sont nos maîtres c'est elle qui
nous apprenne quelles sont les questions
que nous devons nous poser parce que ces
questions les déchire à l'intérieur
concrètement donc je pense que ça c'est
tout à fait essentiel après nous
commençons à mettre en place
des lieux des coudes dans les diocèses
dans les instituts religieux pour
accueillir recueillir
non seulement la parole des victimes
mais la prendre au sérieux la croire et
puis faire quelque chose toutes les fois
où il faut faire quelque chose y compris
en justice toutes les fois il faut faire
un signalement au procureur où il faut
déclencher une enquête et et pour
réparer ce mal est ce que pour vous ça
passe nécessairement finalement par un
versement d'argent très concrètement
alors pour réparer ce qui est
irréparable il faut beaucoup d'étapes
pour moi la première étape c'est la
reconnaissance de la vérité faire la
vérité c'est la première des choses
faire la vérité dire vraiment dire pour
devrait vraiment charnellement notre
lente vraiment notre honte de ce qui
s'est passé
peut-être de ce qui se passe encore
aujourd'hui parce que ça malheureusement
nous ne serons que plus tard parce que
les victimes parlerons plus tard et la
question de la réparation financière
n'intervient qu'au bout de ce processus
car si vous allez trop vite dans la
question financière ça peut donner ce
sentiment aux victimes qui serait une
tragédie de plus qu'on les achète qu'on
achète leur silence qu'on achète une
sorte de paix avec les élastiques avec
l'argent comme on le voit dans d'autres
dans d'autres milieux
donc je pense qu'à un moment donné il
est nécessaire parce que nos sociétés
sont construites aussi ainsi qu'il y ait
la proposition de sommes d'argent nous
ne savons pas encore comment de par
quels moyens la répression et son coût
en toutefois des étapes préalables la
réflexion les jours oui elle est
vraiment en cours oui elle est en cours
depuis un an et demi déjà
il nous reste quelques secondes
véronique margron mais peut-être qu'ils
à l'assemblée nationale qui avait
également ouvert une commission pour
l'église mais pas seulement vous en
parliez dans le milieu de la culture
dans le milieu du sport ce sont des des
affaires qu'on a pu voir également
est-ce que vous souhaitez que le travail
que vous accomplissez aujourd'hui ils
puissent également servir ses autres
structures servir toute la société est
ce que vous êtes en lien avec des
politiques par exemple bas pour leur
partager vos constatations
alors on est toujours un peu en lien
mais mais je pense que ce qui ce que ce
que nous espérons c'est que
l'extraordinaire travail de la
commission de jean marc sauvé lui fasse
école parce que je pense que nous
verrons lors de son rapport à l'automne
que c'est un travail vraiment exemplaire
en terme de rigueur en termes
d'engagement en termes de scientificité
c'est à dire de prendre l'ensemble des
questions
les archives les témoignages des
victimes des enquêtes sur le terrain et
que vraiment je crois profondément que
ceci donnera quelque chose qui bien sûr
ne sera jamais totalement exact c'est
impossible mais en tout cas donnera à
comprendre un peu de l'ampleur du drame
et du pourquoi de ce drame et je pense
que enfin j'espère en tout cas que ça ça
peut faire école pour d'autres
institutions un grand merci
véronique margron d'avoir accès merger à
vous notre invitation sur rt france je
le rappelle vous êtes la présidente de
la conférence des religieux et
religieuses de france cette émission est
à revoir sur notre site internet
rt france point tv à écouter également
en podcast merci pour votre fidélité
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]